hello little reject nations Greg
al-baqir how do you thin the gamer on
Twitch
andrew is eight or seven eleven on
Twitter but most importantly the movie
source channel on YouTube make sure to
follow these guys as soon as you can hey
everyone
III upon us you guys both play a lot
more video games than I play so why
don't we get into this with Call of Duty
the world war ii III trailer
as I see everything we're a whole new
world I were to find out what she really
made us
I visited all these place destinations
of we really want to go on vacation
[Music]
[Music]
Wow yeah my throat
till masses
cable experience Oh bill - ah that's
been any carrying shotgun I am right
yeah
[Music]
this really feels like an actual battle
don't go pushing out by the 13th
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
the high bodycam dystrophy love all the
crazy guns wouldn't survive in a battle
that many people you have that pistol oh
yeah dude that was that was really
awesome man the attention to detail in
every single moment more than just what
your eye immediately goes to and if
you're just looking at like the shotgun
or assault rifle some places look in the
other corners of the screen you're like
this buildings being exploded and people
are dying over there like every single
frame there was so much detail going on
man that was crazy
Tony you play more ecologies both of us
what else is I'm interested to see it
like we saw it was gameplay so if the
buildings and everything is actually
game destruct like destroyed as it's
shown in the video because if that's
happening then it could just be an
all-out worker where all of a sudden
walls knocks down you go hide behind
there start shooting incredible when it
details ahead this is a beautiful gas I
think what I like like we're kind of
pointing out what movies a minute out
that we watch more like Dunkirk Saving
Private Ryan and I packed already
yeah I mean like I liked how real it
felt like again when you're looking at
guys in the to your right or your left
you see like guys likes being like I
have blown off you see it felt like it
just not only the graphics incredible
but like it feels so real and like
seeing the clips being shelled off and
then seeing the bullets why I just say
it again just that sense of realism it's
like maybe said it best it feels kind of
scary yeah it's scary cuz I'm like oh so
realistic it yeah oh man dude glorifying
World War 2 has never looked more fun
gosh who would I thought you can make a
World War Q a feeling fun thing to pick
up with a controller we knew today
you're playing this when you just build
that same college any kind of style -
but just when the graphics they just
keep getting better and better when they
first were making trailers for like Call
of Duty games the graphics were like
this for the videos just like to show
all this is what's going to happen but
now the graphic finally caught up
towards like you're watching a movie but
this is the actual gameplay yeah so
detailed so beauty yeah nez violent
trailer dude I would like them to take
the advanced warfare technology and then
throw it in World War two I think that
wouldn't have set any colors or even
something that heavy great hi I'm Jim
packing around World War two there yeah
that's company that has a world war two
know me oh so many people love the last
game so I mean it's only gonna work
right what guns are you guys best at
within these shooter games I am great
with a shotgun that's like my specialty
sniper I suck Faton not that a sniper
and I usually like using a machine gun
okay you're good snapper machine I'll go
with the auto man just uh learn how to
like just quick spray don't like mess up
your target so much you get those quick
sprays down I got a lot in me I also
love I mean I figured they're not kind
of this but being such a huge advanced
warfare at love in that game when you
can do thermal vision you can have you
guys on the red in the red like that my
favorite is love now that's when you so
smoke your negative length or man a
little bit I'm you go with a
flamethrower in real life - I begin with
the flamethrower
I'm just run up with whatever that one
guy standing but just look like an AK
maybe just run up Stefan I'm gonna actor
go look back at it felt a little like
Arnold Schwarzenegger commando just
bring out and stuff for like even Jason
phrase 30 inches that's level violent
yeah well yeah they shows it like
stabbings in the last game something I
hope it looks like that every time you
kill somebody because the other ones you
just get a quick stab and they fall down
with this one it looks like do that just
really destroy somebody with when you're
going through yeah well for sure out of
the three of us
Tony will most likely be the one to for
sure by this game yeah he'll be they
want to fish out $75.00 reason to
survive is getting when you get it oh
yeah
create an account on your money and no
make sure I play with your money
they'll play call of duty your money on
my life I mean who else's money will be
using let's look at some that says
estimate I don't but so that's how we do
it we mucho Fredo chop friends at the
couch and when I moved just when I'm
playing xbox yeah right man my friend
buys games I get to play him until we do
it we share in this one I'd say the only
thing that would have made this trailer
any better is it's like Captain America
one damn declaration oh you'll see that
and all that you're gonna be adventure
the Wonder Woman person all you never
knew they were in the warming I watched
the movies alright guys well hey I was a
really cool trailer if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe and become a
part of the reject nation click that
notification that would freezy on
instagram most importantly follow him on
it's in the gamer on twitter live
streams gameplays 50i tweets at a core
711 the most importantly follow him on
the movie source YouTube channel make
sure to check him out there much love to
the reject nation moving on to more e3
convention [ __ ]